معنا من رام الله لواء الركن المتقاعد
واصف عريقات الخبير في الشؤون
الاستراتيجيه والعسكريه ضيفنا مرحبا بك
اذا بالنسبه لهذه التفاهمات ما الذي تقراه
من طبيعه المرحله المقبله في التواجد
الاسرائيلي على هذا
المحور يعني اعتقد انه اسرائيل ما زالت
تعتقد بانه محور فيلادلفيا هو الهدف
الاستراتيجي الذي سيحقق لها كل ما عجزت عن
تحقيقه في الشمال وفي الوسط وفي الجنوب
وانا بتقديري هذه يعني رغبات اسرائيليه من
الصعب ان تصبح هذه الرغبات حقيقه واقعه
لانه تنفيذها ليس سهلا وخاصه ان هناك
اتفاقيات سواء كانت مع اخواننا المصريين
او مع السلطه الفلسطينيه يعني هناك
اتفاقيات اي تم العمل بها وتم تنفيذها وتم
السيطره على هذا المحور ولكن انا بتقديري
كون اسرائيل فشلت في تحقيق الاهداف تريد
الان ان تلفت الانظار وتركز على هذا
الموضوع ولكن تقديري من ناحيه الشعب
الفلسطيني والمقاومه الفلسطينيه لا لا
يعني لا جديد في هذا الموضوع اذا تواجدت
القوات الاسرائيليه في محور فلادلفيا
سيتم التعامل معها كما يتم التعامل معها
في في بقيه مناطق التي وصلت اليها يعني
ربما الحديث في هذه تفاهمات حول استبدال
التواجد الفعلي لقوات الاحتلال بانشاء
جدار او كاميرات يعني او مجسات او تقنيات
متطوره هل ترجح ذلك و وكيف يختلف عن
العمليه العسكريه في
رفح يعني بالتاكيد
ما ما جرى يوم س7 عش في عمليه طوفان
الاقصى والجدار الالكتروني والسياج
الحديدي والاسوار وكل اجهزه الرقابه لم
تمنع المقاومه الفلسطينيه من اقتحام هذه
المواقع والسيطره عليها فبالتالي انا
بتقديري سيتم التعامل مع اي جدار او اي
حاجز تقيمه اسرائيل اذا ما كان هناك اصرار
من الاسرائيليين انا بتقديري سيتم التعامل
معه كما تم التعامل مع فرقه غزه وجدارها
وحصنها يوم 17 عش بتقدير هذه يعني محاوله
من نتنياهو لاطاله امد القتال لانه يريد
ان يبعد الانظار عن عن عزيمته وفشله في
خان يونس لانه حينما حينما توجه الى
الشمال كان هناك توقعات بانه سيحقق
الاهداف التي انطلق الجيش الاسرائيلي من
اجلها وحينما لم يجد توجه الى غزه والى
المستشفيات وخاصه الى مستشفى الشفاء ولم
يجد هناك ولم يحقق اغراضه فاضطر الى
القبول بال المفاوضات
والهدنه الاسرى ال وذهب بعدها الى خان
يونس على اساس ان هناك يعني منطقه سيحقق
فيها اهدافه سواء كانت على صعيد المقاومه
الفلسطينيه والقيادات او على صعيد تحرير
الاسرى فلم يجد يعني منذ اكثر من شهرين
وهو في خان يونس اذا الان هو يريد ان يبعد
الانظار ويتجه باتجاه محور فلادلفيا انا
اعتقد الاخوه المصريين متنبهين لهذا
الموضوع ولن يقبلوا اي حال من
الاحوال يعني هذه التراهات وهذه
الاقتراحات الاسرائيليه التي ستعقد الموقف
اكثر بكثير م هو عليه ال واذاعه الجيش
تتحدث عن قرب التوصل اي ان الاتفاق حول
العمل في هذه
المنطقه لم يحصل بعد هنا السؤال عن
التفاصيل التواجد الاسرائيلي في هذه
المنطقه قد يتطلب عوده للسكان حسب
الاشتراط المصري عوده ل النازحين الى الى
الشمال وهذه ورقه يعني ان تمت يخسرها
الجيش الاسرائيلي او حتى القاده السياسيون
في في المفاوضات هل ترجح استجابه
اسرائيليه
للمطالب المصريه ام ان اتفاقا قد يجري في
هدن طويله يعني يغير كل هذه التفاهمات
يعني شوف مسرح العمليات الان وميدان
القتال هو ورقه الضغط على كل الاطراف
وبالتالي اي اتفاق لا يقبل به الشعب
الفلسطيني ولا تقبل به المقاومه
الفلسطينيه سيبقى ناقصا حقيقه وانا اعتقد
انه الاخوه المصريين ينسقون ينسقون مع
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في قطاع غزه ينسقون
مع السلطه الفلسطينيه في هذا المجال
فبالتالي اي اتفاق يجب ان يتم بموافقه
الفلسطينيين وما عدا ذلك
سيبقى في في حاله يعني
حرب شكرا جزيلا لك اللواء الركن المتقاعد
واصف عرقات الخبير في الشؤون الاستراتيجيه
والعسكريه من رام الله